syndiqués ou non employés du secteur
public ou privé et qu'importe le diplôme
qu'elle possède
les femmes gagnent moins d'argent que
les hommes c'est acceptable c'est sûr
mais non ce n'est pas surprenant faut
négocier il faut s'informer pour savoir
qu'est ce qu'on vaut ça devrait même
avoir été changés à très très longtemps
j'en parlais avec ma petite fille riche
de molière à comprenez postule
les femmes représentent environ la
moitié des salariés du québec mais elles
gagnent en moyenne près de 3 2 lors de
l'heure de moins que leurs collègues
masculins
soit 25 dollars 19 de leurs alors que
les hommes touche 28 de leurs six de
leurs mais comment explique-t-on chez et
corps encore si présent beaucoup
d'employeurs vont continuer de perpétuer
ce qu'on appelle le modèle pourvoyeur
ménagères une femme qui par exemple
s'absente pour un congé de maternité
peut-on écopé à son retour si on a des
clients des gros dossiers défendent eux
perdu parce qu'on a pas été là et puis
l'organisation fait en sorte que ça a
continué on a donné les clients d'autres
personnes et puis au final ben ça fait
qu' on est obligés d falloir commencer
mais alors comment renverser la vapeur
je n'hésiterai pas à recourir à des
amendes par exemple ou à des pénalités
financières
il faut davantage que les entreprises
soient obligés de démontrer qu'elle
travaille activement à crise du milieu
de travail
exemple de billets une méthode déjà
utilisée par certains gouvernements
scandinaves et qui a fait ses preuves
selon cette professeure l'institut de la
statistique est incapable d'expliquer
cet écart entre les hommes et les femmes
mais l'expérience sur le marché du
travail la situation familiale et la
durée dans un même emploi peuvent être
une piste de réponse ici qui me
remettent radio canada montréal